Like for example, I wouldn't even walk on the same side of the
street as a kid um like in real life um just because
Uh um
Hold on.
Wait. Why the
Why the did she press down on this? Why the could she go out
of her way to freak out on Dan over this? Because even even seeing
a kid um would trigger me. Even seeing it would trigger me and
then I wouldn't I would avoid it and I wouldn't even >> have
you developed such
Wait. Please tell me trigger in this case doesn't mean what I
think it means.
What do we got? We got this one. What is this one? >> a
partner?
I like feminine Andy. But do you like it more or less than like
masculine Andy? I want cute little girl that I can wrap my arms
around.
So you like being like in the dominant role. Yes.
Like a partner? Cool. Now on its own, not damning, okay? On its
own, not damning. Weird given some of the other
Right? Cuz that makes it physical, that makes it real, it makes
it in the real world. But hold on. I'm in I'm I'm only into the
most feminine of the most feminine. That's what I'm Wait, what
does that mean? I need to I need to have a little girl to wrap
myself around. Oh, like you're like
big spoon is what you're saying.
Oh, I get you. >> I need to have like a 12-year-old. Just
in case you actually thought for a second, "Oh, this is just
like big little stuff. That's totally normal."
No.
No. No. No. No.
Oh boy. All right, that's
Yikes. What do you want to call them a Okay, that would be really
If you guys
this person a for some reason after these comments, that would
be really inappropriate. Oh, we we've still got some more food
shop stuff. We get some more content.
Let's see here. Probably going to watch this clip from the therapy
thing, the exposure therapy. The old Queenman bot.
>> that would be associated with kids because I would be
like I would avoid errands that would be associated with kids
because I would be like, "Oh my god, I don't want to even like
associate with it because it would give me so much anxiety and
it would send me into like a panic attack." Well, not a panic
attack, but an anxiety attack, right? Um
So FoodShop's basically
expresses some attraction to kids.
Gets totally mobbed for it. Tries to pivot into saying, "I went
to therapy. I have POCD." This thing that like it's OCD or something.
It's you have compulsive thoughts about images of kids, but you
don't have like the long-term persistent attraction to kids.
So she she tries to come up with this excuse when she realizes
how bad it sounds. Then eventually she pivots into a different
one. She pivots into I think she just stops discussing it entirely
after this, right? She basically says, "Don't call me a I'm not
anything like that." But she's put all the content online where
she's talked about wanting to have a 12-year-old wrapped around
her, where she's talked about this whole thing where she's going
to explain that she avoided errands apparently that would be
around kids. She's done a whole bunch of stuff to try to deal
with this POCD, quote unquote.
Seems like Queenman's analysis, we might maybe we could go back
at some point. Should we go back now? Seems like Queenman's analysis
is something along the lines of well, it she's it seems like
she looked up POCD.
Tried to take those criteria and then tried to create a hypothetical
that perfectly exemplifies those criteria that makes no sense.
I might I think I should go back. I think I should go back and
listen to what this hypothetical is. >> stigmatized because
we don't want to encourage that attraction.
We don't want to say that that attraction
is okay. We want to say no, we would prefer that people were
not attracted to kids. So that is the stigmatization. Yeah, yeah,
I think And the person that you want to stigmatize like you said
because they didn't choose that attraction. Let's speed this
up. Let's speed this up. >> that attraction, that person
should be destigmatized. You know you know what's the funniest
thing, but also like really ironic? I think it's just the amount
of exposure therapy that I went through is what [__]
me over um because I >> She's now calling her off the exposure
Was that Kenny? I just heard Kenny laugh. That was Kenny's laugh.
That I think that's about to be all that she's going to say.
I think that's what she's going to say. have POCD, but I went
through um I guess self-treatment for POCD to the point where
>> Oh, never mind.
So this is her self-treatment for POCD is off the
Sorry, drawing depictions of kids in situations, in hardcore
situations, okay? That was her self-prescribed treatment for
these thoughts she was having about minors.
>> Yeah, I I guess I Oh, Becky, I remind you to stop talking
about this immediately. me the
out of here, dude.
It's insane. went through self-treatment
Kenny is literally like, "No, you're my favorite Stop talking
about this. I don't want you to be outed. Kenny, Kenny, you're
being outed, bro. No." POCD to the point where I became so un-icked
when it came to the subject that like now I talk about it so
unfiltered to the point where I became so like un-cognizant to
how other people react to it that like I just like no longer
become cognizant to how other people react to it and then like
that [__] me over. Um
Dude, this person literally does not under Like they actually
just say things with no attachment to like they're not trying
to be at a meeting at a meeting. They're just like saying words
over and over and over again.
Like she's trying to say I'm I you know I this became so normalized
for me that I talk about it and it weirds people out and I have
no idea. But she's just like
just keeps doing the word salad over and over again. Yeah, if
that makes sense. I don't know if that makes sense. >> Okay.
No, I'm really wanting to ask questions about the self-treatment
exposure therapy because it sounds a little We're getting into
some territory where I'm like, "Wait a minute, what are you talking
about?" >> That's what I'm We can we can we can get into
that. We can get into that. I'm right here. Now don't worry about
And she's agreeing? So So meanwhile, um can I So you had doubts
about um you had doubts on uh Yes, that is what she's saying,
Frugals. Yes. She is saying she watched so much she dropped out
of so much of the
to try to get rid of these thoughts she had about children
that she forgot that children was weird to other people.
And then she started talking about it in public on her stream.
That is that is her Those are her words precisely. So when Dan
calls her a and she calls him a in return, I would ask, "Does
Dan have any similar clips on the internet? Does Dan have anything
like this on the internet where he talks so much he thinks it's
so normal to say kids he just talks about it repeatedly? Is there
anything like this for Dan? Cuz when Dan says it, I see a basis,
I see some merit to the claim. When FoodShop says it, it seems
like it's just a child getting mad that they're being outed for
stuff they have said on the internet and it's been recorded.
of what I went through, right? So I'm going to send you some
things, all right? Um So The doubts were because of the way you
verbally described them the first two times I heard it when you
in your first conversation with Rezi your first one-on-one conversation
with them from a couple months ago and then your conversation
with Tom when he was covering the map panel. And those two descriptions
did not match up with what I understood about uh about POCD.
So and we went over it on stream and went through the International
OCD Foundation's uh article on it and went through all the details
and it still didn't line up with even what that was describing.
>> Sure, I can I can explain, yeah. So but first of all,
before we get through that, um this is the uh uh I just sent
you a picture. This is um this is the Sertraline that I take,
the little actual pill bottle that I take. Um so I'm going to
pull the Sertraline it's prescribed for a number of different
illnesses. It's up for chat. Yeah, so you can you can see the
cat on there. Um that's me. Um and uh this is I I I know that
you don't doubt
Oh, also just to be clear, when we say you like are in a community,
by the way, if you're watching this, if you've come from FoodShop's
community, we say you're in a community, this is what we're referring
to. You are in a literal community. You until proven otherwise,
we consider all of you It's okay. You will have to gain back
normal human being status over time in any other community, okay?
You come back here from that community, you're a until proven
otherwise, okay? Not sure how that happens, but listen. We'll
figure it out. >> me, but I know there's a lot of people
out there in the audience that doubt me. So mainly just pulling
this up there for the internet to see. Um yeah, here you go,
guys. Uh this is this is Sertraline. I'm just letting you guys
know that wow, like I know that yeah, I know that people out
there doubt me, so there you go. Well, it's it's it's an SSRI
primarily prescribed or often prescribed for people who have
uh
But it that doesn't necessarily mean that it's treating specifically
POCD. Yeah. Cuz if I mean she
Bugs got it immediately. You never share this. You are a total
lolcow for sharing this, okay?
But if you were going to share it,
I think if you I'd want to see what doctor prescribed it. So
it's actually a psychiatrist? >> Yeah, you got to wait.
Let's go dig into She's taking pictures of her medication to
prove >> information. Yeah, to prove it all online. Ridiculous,
man. It's brilliant. I love having seen just a lolcow controversy
in real time. It's been great. categorization of an a pure obsessive
disorder that is um usually it's it's more like a talk therapy
addressed kind of thing as opposed to like a chemically treated
thing. Yeah. And And by the way, I I just want to let you guys
know that I am under no obligation to show you guys this. I'm
basically like diving into my own privacy to like show you guys
this. Like it's pretty insane like what I'm like diving into
my own privacy to show you guys this. Oh my god. Somebody just
sent me a apparently there was a manifesto on this.
She wrote a whole manifesto on this topic. We're going to keep
watching. And trust me, listen. You guys can subscribe. I haven't
shilled a single time this stream. You can subscribe if you like
the content, okay? But
we're we're just going through we're going to get this all done
in like one go, okay? I'm like feeling kind of awake. I'm feeling
kind of into the content now, so we should get through all of
this stuff in one go. We can read the manifesto after this. Uh
we could maybe split it into multiple days. We'll see. Who this?
Who that? Who this? Who that? Wait, what's up? Can I Can I spoil
like one the only important aspect of the the manifesto?
What is the only Okay, fine.
What is the only important aspect of the >> versions of
the manifesto. There's the released version that they posted
and then there's the edited version. And the version that they
released after this, they explain what is as drawn child and
say that they to drawn child,
And then in the edited version, they redact that while I believe
either live or shortly after Queen and covered it, they changed
that to not say
They change it to to say I believe like depictions of children.
So initially in their mind when they're just writing this out
when they're explaining what they off to, they describe it themselves
as drawn child. Yeah. Yeah, it's not shocking. That is not
>> Then after people reacted to that, they they changed
it. I believe it was I was told by someone I don't know how true
it is. I believe it was live while Queen and reading it they
changed it or it was like shortly after. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, doesn't that change if they consider
if they consider lolly con drawn child, doesn't that change the
color of certain DMs we were just reading? Um. Again, again I'm
just going to ask I'm just going to ask, okay? I'm just going
to ask. When she says, "Oh, I've met a cute this cute IRL Japanese
girl, okay?" When she says this and she believes that is drawn
depictions of depictions of children, when she she she said IRL,
I I don't know, man. I don't know, man.
I don't know, man. >> Listen, I did I delete I might have
deleted my food shops folder. Okay, well, I don't think I have
I might have it in Discord or or something. Someone if Dicker
sent it to you then he sent you the uncensored version he said.
But yeah. Yeah, Dicker Dicker sent it to me. Yeah. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, also Queen
he came around and said, "Hearing Dan came back for TPD." Yeah,
he did. Well, I don't Thank you, Maral. Sorry, I didn't say bye.
Bye. But Dan Dan threw a couple messages in my Discord. I didn't
even hear about it. I just heard that Food Shops was going after
Dan and I was like, "Oh, this is going to go disastrously for
them." And then I realized they're going after Dan for calling
them a I'm sorry. That is just well-established fact. It's been
been out here on the internet. At the very least,
if you want to if you want to call Dan a In this case, what Food
Shops did was advocate for Dan to be doxxed and swatted. So she
hopes she hopes Dan gets doxxed and swatted. If you want to do
that, you better have some examples of Dan being a bad person
in the same way of of having something similar. She's also calling
Dan a
you have to have something similar going on, right?
But I don't think we're going to find anything similar on Dan.
Let's keep listening to this for a little bit. I think we'll
do we'll do a little bit more of this. This is a funny conversation.
That was cute That was That was Food Shops being told, "Hey,
Kiwi Farms is like looking into you right now." Not great.
That's That's her response to it. It was like, "Ah, I'm going
to end up on there eventually anyway."
Oh, so she she's just leaking emails with her therapist?
Is this her therapist?
In 2021,
okay. God, this is not in a high number of ways.
Okay, blah blah blah blah blah. Before your job starts, think
to anxiety or depression. Right now you have to time to exercise
daily. You do anything you like as long as it's an aerobic exercise
you spend 30 minutes on. If that's too much, you can start at
like 15 or 20 minutes. You slowly work your way up to 30. You
need to find a doctor.
Having time off before your job starts is a good opportunity
to take care of things. In addition to a doctor,
do you have a dentist in the area? Eye doctor? Do you So you
can start looking up doctors for hormone therapy. Start with
hot big hospitals, blah blah blah blah blah. So nothing about
POCD, nothing about
I don't see anything about her
like purported attraction to kids in the message from the doctor,
okay? The first appointment kind of Um, right? I didn't get it
as it So she's basically like what I just said. Um, having time
off before your job starts is good. Um, you need to find a doctor
like a primary care doctor is good. And then I basically say,
"Yeah, that's like cat right there." And I say like OCD, right?
Um, and yeah, a lot of personal details on here in Okay, so you
said this to a therapist.
Okay, so what she actually said Right, let's actually go through
these emails cuz she's not she's got to swing over.
Wait. Shouldn't this be like
Would this be I'm trying to think of how Gmail orders things.
Is this Would this be the first email and this this the second
email? Yes, next works next blank works perfectly fine. I think
I will in fact try to exercise more actively today even after
work starts. I'll also try to find ways to exercise. I'll update
you, blah blah blah blah blah. Um, the good news is that my major
prescriptions for propranolol and buspar for have 5 months for
refill left in the bottle. So I can just get these refilled at
a pharmacy like blank.
Have been in fact doing all the stuff in number three mostly
except for seeing friends back at home.
One of the one of my close childhood friends is in Hawaii and
won't be back until approximately a month later. So my friends
want to hold off on hanging out until he returns.
So I can't do anything about that. However, that's weird. Your
friends don't want to hang out with you until the other person's
around. That's strange. However, I've been reconnecting with
people actively online by asking to play video games with me
over voice and long distance, of course. So that has been helping
me distract from my OCD. My roommate helps with a My roommate
helps a lot
by doing stuff with him in general like going out to eat or exploring
San Francisco or just shopping together in general so he could
provide me some degree of social interaction at the very least.
I do not have an eye doctor. I do not have a blah blah blah blah
blah dentist either which is important for me as my glasses need
replacing. However, I'm not in a rush for either of these just
yet, but I will be on the lookout for them after I set up a primary
doctor for myself. As for hormone replacement therapy, thank
you for emailing us at therapist. Please let me know what she
says and what resources I can
be pointed to on HRT or pointed to to get on HRT as soon as possible.
Thank you very much. I look forward to our next session. So this
doesn't sound like anything to do with POCD. The [__]
See if you can find someone and get an appointment soon. If you
don't like her you can switch to someone else in a
In addition to doctor, do you have a dentist in this area? Eye
doctor? There's nothing about POCD yet, but she's she has mentioned
those things. There's no diagnosis here.
No evidence of a diagnosis.
It's self-reporting.
What is What is the email supposed to
I can get on HRT as soon as possible
in 2021. Okay, turns out I'm having a [__] um yeah,
so again this is this is what happens when a doctor doesn't mention
to me only she mentioned to me. I have to like prove things to
you guys. I don't know. So >> have to prove anything. Doctor
doesn't even mention OCD.
She mentions OCD to the doctor and it's not POCD. Doctor has
no idea about that. >> That's the thing. That's the most
important thing to recognize is you don't have to actually able
to do yourself right now. Yeah, this is just total [__]
up behavior and stuff like this. And the more you engage with
it the more likely you're to you are to anything that Oh, she
reported she reported to a therapist that she had OCD That is
the only thing she's shown us. So she reported to a therapist
that she had OCD. More inconsistencies that will be used against
you making you feel like you need to do more to prove things,
Yeah, no. I'm only showing I'm only putting this out there to
show some people maybe to like make people realize like just
how far they're going with this, okay? Um, because sometimes
sometimes it takes a little shocker to make them realize like
just
Yeah, no. I'm only showing I'm only putting this out This is
like the LegalMindset video, okay? Do you guys remember when
Alex Nevell made the like made made a an allegation that LegalMindset
was like inappropriate with a minor and
he did a video that like didn't conclusively disprove any of
it and was like, "Now that this is disproven, I hope I'll never
have to deal with this again." It's like, "Bro, I didn't think
the allegation held any water, but you just disproved nothing.
You said like literally nothing."
He was like his his action his reaction was so weird. It actually
cast more suspicion on him. He was like, "Oh, yeah, that laptop
he said I laptop and phone where he said I might have a child
on those. No, those are for work and I didn't care about those.
Yeah, I reported the change missing in my car, but I didn't care
about the laptop or phone those." Like, "What? That makes no
sense. Are you serious?"
Do you know if the timeline for this means she's talking about
her roommate Sashi line Lord who's kicking her out? No, I have
no idea. The This is all like 2021. So
these The stream is from 2023. The email is from 2021.
Four years ago. >> show some people maybe to like make
people realize like just how far they're going with this, okay?
Um, because sometimes sometimes it takes a little shocker to
make them realize like just how far like this little hunt has
gone, you know? Um, because in in my in my opinion in my opinion
it's like it's like people don't really realize like how far
they're willing to prosecute a person and not realize like how
human they are until like they're asking for literally their
personal info on like, "Oh, yeah, what medication bottles are
you getting?" Like what kind of like what kind of letters are
you sending back and forth with your [__] therapist,
right? Like
Nobody I mean this None of that helped you. Hold on. What is
she saying? Oh, actually the allegations of Based on Based on
her, Food Shops talking about like her thoughts about children.
People called
And now she's saying because they're calling me a pedo, I had
to disprove it by doing all of this crazy sh And none of the
crazy sh she did disproves anything.
She posted emails that have nothing to do with POCD or thoughts
about children. She posted a medication that has nothing to do
with thoughts about children.
She disproved nothing and it's from
So she's apparently been off the lolicons for a long time if
it was tied in any way to those emails. Information is so [__]
So crazy, man. So insane. She's just like pumping out info I'm
prompted. No, no such a person has asked anything of this nature.
You asked if you would have a private one with snow all women
are pedophiles. If you want to take a picture of all the pedophiles
none of them can be sure I agree with I agree with you that you
know it's not outside the norm for women so there's no point
in even diagnosing them as pedophiles. But all women are pedophiles,
you know. person and like like they're not under any obligation
to be like like at all. It's insane. Um but here I am like giving
you guys this information so yeah. Like [__] man,
whatever. I don't care anymore. Like these are things that usually
people pull out of you like because they're doctors to you. But
I'm here I am like giving you guys this [__] so What
the [__] how is that? What is she saying here? Usually
have doctors give this information but I'm just giving it okay.
And before I like ask him more specific self-treatment thing
and more specifics but um one thing to point out um you were
posted so yeah you were posted on Dev stream it's a pretty brief
mention though. It's a couple posts where people are basically
saying that Dev has been collabing with you and of course using
not so friendly terms to describe you but um and then for
Sure Fata Otaku, Dev is a total chaser. He's willing to uh accept
this person's lies, validate them all all in order to get gawk
pictures. Dev is the least honest, most degenerate commentator
in all of politics, okay? And I say that with Destiny around.
Dev is Dev is a bigger liar Dev is not personally involved. Dev
just lies to try to get gawk pics from random trans people because
he is the most degenerate desperate chaser that exists on the
Now Dev thought that I was kind of sh and before he kind of thought
that I was like put a knife in his back before. No, no, no. You've
shown who you are. You are a disgusting loser, okay? You had
the option to come talk to me. I was willing to talk to you.
Now it's just very obvious it's just very obvious to me that
you lie and you validate this person in order to them in order
to have some sort of sexual relationship with them. You are disgusting,
bro. You are one of the most disgusting people I've seen on the
internet. [__] gross.
Put tea We spit on you, Dev. You're [__] disgusting.
One thing to also keep in mind is the more that you kind of like
post this stuff. I don't know if you shared this certain pic
or the document pic to anybody like beyond like I I hope you
didn't show them on screen I showed them on screen just now.
I can't even have imagined how good this would turn out.
Yeah, I showed both of them. All right. Well, part of the reason
why I'm approaching this differently like you were saying that
you know there's a human element and everything. I have a couple
different approaches I can take. Obviously. I mean you've seen
the way I've engaged with some people like Lab for instance.
I'm sure you've probably seen some of that and I can be more
aggressive at certain points but it depends on the person. So
if the person seems like they're purely being malicious I'm going
to say good cop today or I'm going to play bad cop I don't know
if I can say that. Sorry, bro. [__] then I don't
really have a reason to be nice or to be you know overly cautious
with them or anything like that. But with you from what I've
been able to tell I don't see like like a definite threat. I
don't see a big risk with you. I don't see someone who's trying
to go out of their way hurting people. Somebody was asking me
in in my chat yesterday hey or yeah yesterday why don't you think
there's an issue if she keeps growing as like an influencer don't
you think she would you know potentially be tempted to have access
to to kids with the power that she has? And I was like no. I
don't think so because already you've gotten a bit of attention.
You've had some growth. You're not at like a huge room but you've
had some growth. And this pretty big kind of like scandalous
thing from most people's perspective came out back on the 15th.
And usually the way things go is once something like that goes
public next thing you know there's a whole bunch of DMs leaked.
So if there were any kind of conversations between you and minors
we would have people coming and talking on stream about it. We
would have DMs being leaked. Like minors would have already came
forward to like like literally talk about it honestly like if
there was already
There would be lots of stuff coming to the fore by now and so
no I don't really see that as a big threat. So that's why I'm
trying to be cautious with this trying to be open with you. But
um you know what I'm saying trying to give you some advice at
the same time. But that'll being said I do want to know about
the the self-treatment stuff cuz that actually has curious. So
you said you had your own self-treatment approach to exposure
therapy. So usually uh people do not um people should not like
uh try to uh go through treatment on their own in terms of OCD
just because of like Why is she the exception for everything?
Because Destiny is, bro. Destiny is. um It is without like a
guidance from like a Wait, what did Kenny say? in terms of OCD
just because of like
Why was this never featured on YouTube? Wait, it was featured.
Queenie covered all of this. What are you talking about? Queenie's
got a whole food shop saga video or video list. He's got a whole
He's got a whole list of this.
Now we've got Trust me, we've got a video after this as well.
We've got the the manifesto we've got all of that how hard Because
Destiny is, bro. Because Destiny is. CD just because of like
um how hard it Why Oh, why is these Why is she the exception
for everything? Because Destiny is. Because Destiny is, bro.
Because Destiny is. um It is without like a guidance from like
a professional. Um but this is like one of the few things that
um I did put myself through. Um and She said she completed therapy
for her
But what she means is she completed self-therapy. And one of
these things like before I sought out like a mental health specialist.
Like for example, I wouldn't even walk on the same side of the
street as a kid um like in real life um just like I had
Hold on.
Wait, why the
why the [__] did she press down on this? Why the
[__] would she go out of her way to freak out on
Dan over this?
You have clips like this out there.
Why in the world would you get mad if somebody Dude, all you
do is slink off into the corner when they call you a pedo, okay?
Slink off into the corner
Don't get mad. Don't press them. Don't advocate. Don't say you
hope that they get doxxed and swatted.
Don't say you're glad that their wife is getting harassed at
their workplace because they've been doxxed and they're being
harassed by schizos on the internet. Don't say sh like that.
Are you serious?
I We got to listen to that again. She just said she basically
doesn't trust herself around children. One of these things like
before I sought out like a mental health specialist. Like for
example, I wouldn't even walk on the same side of the street
as a kid um like in real life um just
She was so She was so concerned
about
thoughts that she couldn't walk on the same side of the the street
as other kids apparently.
Bro, this is just so insane. Sonia one There's only one Can we
just say there's only one? So hard. Why is this language?
Why? Why?
I'm still I'm stunned that someone would say that. Uh yeah. Information
you couldn't waterboard out of me. Episode 576.
I was just like incredibly definitely scared of kids. Um I'm
sorry. This is another like example of why this person is like
like shouldn't be platformed like they're a total weirdo. This
is another reason, right? They can't even understand that they
shouldn't be doing any of this that this is all a bad idea that
this is all a mistake. They have no concept of what they should
and shouldn't put on the internet. It's just there's nothing
There's nothing connecting them to reality. in general because
I would be so scared that I was like a real um that I would convince
myself I was a monster um that uh that even being like even breathing
like the same air as children would be like a
Dude, what?
I I
She was so Bro, if you can be convinced that you're a You don't
get to get You don't You no longer have the privilege to be upset
when other people call you a pedo, okay?
You do not.
You should always be honest. Yes, it looks insane that they're
getting mad at Dan and saying Dan deserves to be doxxed and swatted
be for calling her a which has clips like this on the internet.
Hey, you know who also called you a pedo, Food Shops? You.
You called you a pedo, okay? If you can call you a pedo, then
Dan can call you a pedo. That's just how it is. >> like
be a violation, right? Um so uh yeah I wouldn't even be like
within 10 ft of them. So so the the exposure would be like walking
on the same side of the street as them would be like um even
like like I think one time I high-fived a kid like a random kid
and that's it um like nothing
One time she high-fived a random kid.
What? What What Like like I think one time I high-fived a kid
like a random kid and that's it um like nothing
I imagine she high-fived a kid. I imagine she high-fived a kid.
What What are you doing?
Children are terrified of you. Let's be real, okay? Bro, come
on. One time I just high-fived a random kid. The exposure would
think one time I the same side of the street as them would be
like um even like like like I think one time I high-fived a kid
like a random kid and that's it um like nothing
I imagine she high-fived a kid. I imagine she high-fived a kid.
What What are you doing? Is that self-defense? Is that self-defense?
I'm I'm anticipating the kids' answers to start off with a cauterizing
a wound then it's a self-defense situation, yeah. nothing crazy.
It's just high-fiving them. And then another thing is like for
example
yeah I don't know. It It's It's just like like just walking the
same side of the street as them um and just generally like like
for example another thing is that um if I visit a random ass
uh website um and uh if I if I visit like um any kind of website,
okay? Literally any website um like for example um Just like
ballpark, how long do you think this person can describe in the
most effusive and confident ways possible their attraction to
children and how powerful it was their attraction to children?
How many times can they do that before it's okay for the rest
of the of us to call them a
Like how many times do they have to How many times do they have
to do it?
Dude, I Hold on. The feeling you have to when you high-five a
kid to prove it didn't make you stiff. You ugh ugh I'm trying
to think.
Trying to come up with an example.
I'm just throwing one out here, okay? Um like a like a school
lunch website, right? If it's a school lunch website and it has
originally it has a kid on What the [__] is she saying?
What is she saying? It's a school lunch website. What is this?
Who visits that? Um Is she a parent?
I'm just throwing one out.
Wait, that's a great point from Kenny. Wait, why would you go
to school lunch website? What the What purpose could you possibly
have in going to that? What I don't even know what the you're
talking about. Were you just looking up random elementary schools,
clicking around, or What's going on here, bro? What is
Yeah, I was just on this random school lunch website for an elementary
school near me.
I was not trying to figure out what time lunch time is. I was
not trying to figure figure out the perfect time to strike. I
was just chilling. Trying to see what kids eat these days. Okay.
Um like a like a school lunch website, right? If it's a school
lunch website and it has originally it has a kid on there. Um
Uh and then I would avoid it, right? Because even even seeing
a kid um would trigger me. Even seeing it would trigger me and
then I wouldn't I would avoid it and I wouldn't even
What? Wait. Please tell me trigger in this case doesn't mean
what I think it
This dude, what the
Why would you ever
Again, my only question is it's not even like obviously this
is all [__] up. Food shops is a person always has
been. Whatever. But like why?
All you had to do is not put this on the internet in public for
people to record and and laugh at and
immortalize. That's all you had to do.
You could have like kept the whole Destiny bag.
But like there's no way people will see this and want to keep
watching you, right? Wouldn't that mean like all of Destiny's
community is like totally cool
You guys aren't cool with are you? I mean Destiny watches this.
If Destiny were to watch this, he would just be jealous of food
shops, right? Food shops doesn't even need to get hard. She just
look at a random picture of a kid. She watches Barney the dinosaur
and she's hard, okay? Destiny could never. Destiny could never.
for lolicon. Go to website >> A lot of this stuff now as
well is all been so post hoc. Like she's She knows what people
have been saying about it and she's understands that her explanation
previously which she's given to different conditions etc. were
so [__] She's gone down and she's gone through everything
and researched it and she's coming up with these like in-depth
excuses about things which just make it sound much worse because
it's it doesn't correlate with what you said previously and it
sounds like you're [__] trying to come up with some
kind of damage control some rationalization for >> Well,
you you're never going on a school lunch website. Like you're
not you're not a parent that gets lunches for your kid in school.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on, Kilo. Listen, that was pretty tongue-in-cheek
on my part, I thought. No? You're not You didn't high-five a
kid. You did not high-five a kid. That did not happen.
It's It's insane. It's Literally, okay. So, this is where we
started, right? This is where we started with the clips.
I think the funny part about this is we went back that context
was critical. Yeah, all of these examples are clearly totally
made up. They're not They don't map onto She She just described
her sexual attraction to children before this and now she's trying
to figure out how to pathologize it in a way that makes her innocent.
That's what's really happening here, okay? She actually is a
She actually has a primary sexual attraction to young kids and
after being attacked online for that primary sexual attraction
to kids, she has decided to come up with some sort of excuse,
some sort of way to describe a pathology that makes her innocent
that says, "Oh, I could I'm just I've been cured of my OCD and
I don't I don't want to [__] kids
That's what she's trying to propose to everybody and it's total
It's obviously such obvious ridiculous examples where she's just
trying to get at the the element that she thinks will convince
people that she's not actually pedo. That is or will convince
people that that she actually has pure OCD. She's just trying
to get at those specific elements in her hypothesis which she's
coming up with don't actually map onto what we what we know of
her and the impression she gives off. I would avoid errands that
would be associated with kids because I would be like, "Oh my
god, I don't want to even like associate with it because it would
give me so much anxiety and it would send me into like a panic
attack." Or not a panic attack but an anxiety attack, right?
Um so, part of that exposure therapy is forcing me to engage
with that website. Is forcing me to walk on the same side of
the street of them. Is forcing me to actually like talk to strangers
and and like etc., right? So,
Okay, so she I I This could be or could not be from a
Oh, man. I almost wonder, okay. I almost wonder if she like has
looked up the treatment for OCD in this case and has decided
that exposure therapy is the most common way to deal with OCD.
You deal You deal with your like your being exposed to the things
that like make you scared that make you spiral and then you you
learn how to handle it, right? And then she's just added the
other part to like the the POCD. She's like, "Oh, this is all
a part of my exposure therapy." It feels totally made up. Like
or maybe maybe in some world she gets treatment for OCD and has
nothing to do with POCD. But she's decided to wrap all of this
in so that she can try to pathologize it, try to say it's something
that's been >> So so so yeah, it it's like it's
Not even that They would not answer my second question. Okay,
you want me to show your super chats on stream. So, you said
these things. Hold on a second. You said You super chatted said,
"How many times have you gone to therapy for your
Uh did they answer this one?
I think the answer was once, right?
And then you then you super chatted to ask, "Do you still F clap
to it though
And they would not answer that question. I mean we have 2024
of them sending stuff to that other person to jerk off and apparently
there are voice voice memos of them pretending to be kids doing
[__] with each other. Gross.
So, I I kind of doubt that any of that has stopped. It's like
all these things. Yeah. And eventually after I got I got like
with my therapist my OCD specialist >> Oh, wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. That could make some sense. Interesting. >> therapist
I think my OCD uh
specialist therapist said this. Um I was like I was like, "Oh
yeah, I consume you know, I consume like
and stuff like that, right? And then I always feel bad because
I have POCD
and you know, how the [__] do I get over my POCD?"
And then my my therapist says like, "You know, it seems like
you already treat yourself mostly, right? Like 80% there. I honestly
think that one of the exposure therapy stuff that you should
try and I don't really care
Hold on. This is This is a big one. Hold on. This got to be I
got to make sure I'm actually paying attention here.
I distinctly remember her saying her attraction has not changed
around 3 months ago. Jesus. >> Like that, right? And then
I always feel bad because I have POCD
and you know, how the [__] do I get over my POCD?
And then my my therapist says like, "You know, it seems like
you already treat yourself mostly, right? Like 80% there. I honestly
think that one of the exposure therapy stuff that you should
try and I don't really care if like you consuming is like a good
thing or not. What matters is that it's helpful to you is that
you should consume and then and then literally that was one of
the stuff that her therapist
So, her therapist said, "Listen, you've already treated yourself
mostly. You're like the ideal the ideal client, okay? You've
mostly treated yourself for OCD. I think you should go the extra
mile and jerk off to a lot of lolicon cuz that will help with
your attraction to kids, your POCD.
All right, can we get a single yes therapeutic prescription,
okay?
This is This is more rare. Like back in the day it used to be
about, you know, trying to get a doctor to write you a prescription
for weed. Now it's about trying to get a doctor trying to get
a doctor, sorry, to write you a prescription for lolicon.
Food shops got the golden ticket for every Okay, you Listen.
Jerk off to drunk kids. Try it. Try it. Try jerking off to drunk
kids. This will help, for sure. Oh, it makes sense now. No, you
justified. Why? No. Why? Bro. the prescriptions is consuming
lolicon. I was away for 2 weeks.
That sounds wild to me. >> Okay, thanks. Jesus Christ.
>> Really? Mhm. So so one one of these things one of these
things is Second that your therapist would tell you to jerk off
to the What the [__] is um literally that uh if you
want to
like be able to have exposure therapy like like you like you
should actually have like exposure therapy where you are no longer
afraid of your POCD and then feeling anxiety because of your
POCD
um that is like literally one of the final steps. Um and then
so then to get over your
A lot of a a big part a a lot of a lot of OCD related things
is
Like all you have to think about here, okay? All you have to
think about
is how
dead this person's career would be,
How dead would this therapist's career be if she actually said
to this person, "Oh, you should jerk off to lolicon." And then
they offended.
And then they go, "Oh yeah, my my therapist told me to jerk off
to Dude, that therapist would get lynched.
There would be no malpractice suit. They would lose their license.
There's no shot a therapist would say this. Get the [__]
out of here. What an incredibly preposterous lie.
A lot of OCD related things are said. Wait, I don't get the argument.
Oh, they She got over it, why she still watching it? Why she
still consuming it? Yeah, okay. You just like it. Okay, okay.
You just like it. This by the way all sounds like I I've skimmed
through some of the old
like Q&A videos etc. She was basically treating that as her
own like research program. And this sounds extremely similar
to the conclusions she she made. I wouldn't be surprised if there's
been very little actual conversations related to this stuff with
a an actual therapist cuz there's no [__] way they'd
prescribe this. She's She's She's laughing right now. That's
where That's where the excuses are coming from. This is So, this
is Bog proposing kind of similar to what Ryal said. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. We all see it. Short fat otaku. Chaser's going to chase.
Here he is.
What kind of cancer did I just walk into? Food Chops, you're
supposed to stop. FOOD CHOPS, STOP TELLING EVERYBODY YOU'RE A
FOOD CHOPS, STOP. FOOD CHOPS, NO. I need I need THE FOOD CHOPS,
STOP.
WHAT A DISGUSTING
loser this guy is.
I can't I can't I can't
can't with this guy. Oh my goodness.
said own conclusion.
Yes, but don't chat who seems pretty relatively smart when he
went on Tom's stream, I'd say. I'd say he made good point anyway.
I can't speak to her intelligence as well. I don't think they've
been retired somewhere else, but you know, saying this is the
biggest piece of crap and lies I've ever heard. Yeah, I mean
I think that might be the case. So, we have SFO in chat here
saying What kind of cancer did I walk into? Food Chops, you're
supposed to stop. I just got a response saying you're burning
the bridge with you. It's Sonya burning the bridge. Oh, no. Dev
bro, this is so over. a clinical psychologist or were they just
Uh I like Wait, I like Dev's
video or whatever. His three forms of fascism video, that's a
great video. Uh he is a total loser outside of that video. It's
very clear. Jesus Christ.
>> and OCD specialist.
But were they a therapist or were they a clinical psychologist?
Not a clinical psychologist, a therapist. So, they can't really
prescribe anything then. Um not not not not not It's not a prescription.
It's not a prescription. Yeah, it was just regular uh therapy
sessions. Yeah. Yeah, so they can give recommendations. In a
In a therapist
Uh dude, no no no. His J6 video, his three forms of fascism video,
the thing that makes him disgusting is the fact that he is obviously
somebody who can see things quite clearly, who's very very good
at taking points people make and like coalescing multiple different
points of research into one cohesive idea. He is incredibly good
at sorting out his thoughts. And so, when he decides to defend
Destiny, when he decides to go and defend Food Chops, when he
decides never to talk to anybody else, those are all coherent
like calculated decisions. That is why he is disgusting. He is
not somebody who's reacting, he's not somebody who's like unsure
of what's going on. He knows what's going on. He knows how to
actually prove a point. So, when he does his obfuscation for
certain people, it's very clearly calculated. This guy's trying
to pay his bills. He is a total
loser, okay? It's so much worse because he can see
At least Food Chops has the excuse of being like 80 IQ, like
totally stunted by whatever hormones she's taken, okay? Totally
brain damaged. She has that excuse. Dev does not have that excuse.
Dev is on ironically a very intelligent person. Just
expressedly doing harm for no reason other than, you know, monetary
incentive. It's recommended that you
Like what did they give a Sorry, he's trying to save on OnlyFans
costs. My bad. >> say that you should recommend Well well
well, it was I think I guess like saying it's a recommendation
is a bit misleading. I think it was more like me saying, "Okay,
there's this scenario out here, right? Right saying >> We're
going to change the story. Yeah. Just and then yeah, this like
as soon as you get as soon as you get
Somebody goes, "Hey, that sounds like it's totally unbelievable."
Well, you see, what I just said is not necessarily correct. Hold
on, let me say this again. Wait, what I just said is like not
necessarily correct. Uh let me say that again. Let me say Let
me Let me re Let me restate that, guys. I I know I just got called
out for being like totally wrong. >> recommend Well well
well, it was I I think I guess like saying it's a recommendation
is a bit misleading. I think it was more like me saying, "Okay,
there's this scenario out here, right? >> How many times?
We're going to change the story. Yeah. Just and then yeah, this
like as soon as you get as soon as you get called out on it,
it's the the language shifts ever so slightly. It's a It's She
goes to the hyperbole in most instances to try and make it cement
it like this is a These are kind of terms that clinical terms
etc. that you can't argue against. And then she's got nothing
backing it up cuz she's making it up on the spot. Well, not necessarily
on the spot, but over the course of over the course of time.
And now she's adapting these previous Yeah, conclusions from
previous streams of research programs etc. which now kind of
justify the which she's just willingly getting herself into.
Yeah, so as far as Sonya's like a wizard going to meet someone
20 minutes or Sonya's not like a wizard. Sonya is just the first
person who has had a conversation where they've seriously pressed
on the details of this POCD claim. And the moment someone start
pressing on it, it is all just unraveling. So, credit to Sonya
for doing this. It's It's a good job, but it is not Sonya's not
a wizard. This is This is just
the most basic scrutiny has has just completely made this seem
like a completely insane claim to anyone that didn't already
see it's [__]
Okay. Um I see I see Right, I see out here and I'm like, "Okay,
I'm too afraid to consume it because I'm like, okay, I feel like
my POCD is getting triggered, right?" And then and then the rule
Yeah, that seems reasonable.
She was She was terrified to consume first, guys. That was why
it was a part of her exposure therapy. >> the rule is to
always is to always go the direction of triggering the POCD
Question would be, I guess, why would she be terrified of consuming
or her thoughts towards kids?
And if that thing were a fear of societal judgment or a fear
of harming somebody, then why is she so clearly and so freely
discussing it now? That seems very bizarre to me. OCD on purpose
is to cause the anxiety to happen on purpose in order to um in
order to uh you know, have the exposure therapy happen for you.
Um so, in order to have the exposure therapy to happen for you,
um in that specific case, it is to consume
That I think you said the exact same thing in more words that
our therapist said, "Yes, consume Doesn't sound like a very good
method cuz everything I've seen on ex I don't know enough about
obviously exposure therapies and such, but I would imagine there's
certain types of material which you'd be with that sort of stuff
to avoid all time.
head into exposure therapy like nonstop. Just go and do Yeah,
if you if you feel you have to turn off the light switch three
times, it's not just like, you know, [__] tie your
hands to the radiator. It's going to be like certain types of
stuff like I don't know, like just a really basic like being
being scared of dogs and that kind of stuff. Yeah, because like
the consequences of it aren't that like if if it if if things
go all right versus
exposure to drawn CP
Well, it it just seems like yeah, hold on. POCD, if it was a
thing, would be a compulsion or obsessive thought, but understanding
it's not you. Actively engaging in the behavior willingly is
just you being a Well, I I would say actively engaging in like
continuing to consume the
just because you like it. I mean, that's
Clearly, there's some conflation here where you've had thoughts
towards kids, but you're also very into And I believe in other
streams, I don't know if it's this one, but in some streams,
she discusses actually really liking the power dynamics of being
like the older adult with a child and being trusted and and taking
advantage and using that with them. Kind of like Destiny, to
be honest with you. He describes like turning um Rose into the
perfect little slave or something like that. Right? There's this
idea of having this power dynamic being the the more dominant
person and using that to compel or manipulate groom the other
person into a some kind of relationship.
Food Chops has described sexual getting gratification from those
fantasies
I It's I Surely there's going to be a certain the potential for
it's like desensitization with that kind of stuff. And versus
like I say, just all the basic scenarios that we engaged in.
I don't I mean, for all I know, whether the research is out there
or not, I would I'd be interested to maybe look over it, but
maybe not now. Okay, I know OCD is where off. Try crackers exposure
Uh I see Mantis is in chat here saying, "Stop queen man." Okay.
Exposure therapy for various things, but especially for
well, with certain types of of of issues with OCD, certain types
of obsessions,
they do those in like a controlled setting. So, you're at the
therapist's office and they expose you to certain things to ask
you how you feel and tell you that you're that there's no problem
with this. And in their case, like what I was seeing when it
came to exposure therapy for things like that, they don't even
show you. They're not showing you like nudes of children. They're
like, "Here's a child modeling clothes in a in a catalog or something,
right?" And it's very innocent. There's nothing about it. It's
very mundane. It is just like, what are you Oh, that's actually
That makes way more sense, too. Like why would you explicitly
reinforce the element of it? Yeah?
Like that doesn't seem to make any sense. Why wouldn't you just
be like, "Here's a catalog of kids like some toy catalog or something.
Try to look at this without getting uncomfortable."
Try to look at this without, you know, feel like having a panic
attack. Why would you actually prescribe that you just wouldn't?
You would never. >> feeling about this. It's just a child.
So, tell me what your thoughts are. And that's the exposure therapy.
So, it seems wild that a therapist would tell you to go consume
That doesn't sound right to me. That sounds very irresponsible
for a therapist to do. So, I cannot imagine what her response
to this is going to This is going to be amazing. So, is it okay
if I try to walk you through um the
uh the the specific chart that I drew up? Have you Have you watched
my most
Oh, hold on. Wait. Hold on. She's going to walk us through uh
wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Come on. Come on. Come on.
Come on. Come on. Oh, no. Where is it? Where is it? Where is
it?
Hold on.
I need I need something. Give me a second. Give me a second.
Let's go. DRAW A CHART for me, Food Chops. We have the Connor
Valor media approved seal. All right, we've got the seal of approval.
Let's go. Uh no, I haven't seen it. >> Okay. Guys,
if you watch my recent video for the charts,
for the chart, guys.
Where is it? >> She's got a chart. She's going to show
us, all right. >> Guys, I need to pull this up. I need
to show you guys what she's referring to. You If you were here
earlier, you saw it. You saw my most recent video. You get to
see my most recent video. This is the chart.
Ha ha.
This person's brain is totally fried. Like this person's brain
no work no
Holy sh- Are you serious? Dude, there's no way.
Again, all she had to do was ignore Dan calling her a and none
of this stuff gets gone over by all of these people again, right?
She just had to avoid it. Just ignore it. Just ignore it. Don't
look it up.
But instead, she does this.
>> Guys, that's the chart.
What can we Wait, I missed all of You didn't see this?
OCD, PDF, POCD, anxiety on
b- ba- ba- ba- anxiety on something.
Cons- imply, consume.
Consume,
PDF, consume.
I okay. I Okay, fantastic stuff, okay. >> No, I I Fantastic
stuff, guys. >> This is the chart she drew to explain to
Stardust how she can draw the lolly and still have POCD. Yeah,
man. I- it's a shame that I That would be I would use that as
a thumbnail, but it no one would watch it, but it's I mean, that's
amazing. What Oh, man. I watched it earlier. It's just brilliant,
dude. Holy [__] Um all right, can I can I draw this
thing for you? Sure. She's doing it again. Guys, we're getting
a re- we're getting a re- Okay. Um so uh we have
Listen, the chart before, it was a little confusing. We have
to draw the chart again. It'll make more sense why Food Chops
thought she was a then realized she had POCD, but she still off
the lolly con and because she still off the lolly con, it doesn't
mean she has thoughts about actual kids, okay? Now, this will
all make sense as soon as she can finish the chart, and don't
forget, guys, this is a Connor approved segment, all right? With
the Connor Valor Media seal of approval that's going to go up
here. So, we have OCD. Oh, sorry, can't see this. Give it a look.
>> Um hopefully you can I can see it, yeah. Okay, [__]
I wish I had my pen with me. So, hopefully hopefully So, this
is going to be a little bit complicated, but hopefully you can
sort of wrap your mind around this. So um uh just because, you
know, mental health is sort of a little complicated. So OCD,
all right? So, this is OCD. Um and then on the other side, we
have actual pedo, okay? This is cable. This is cinema. This is
you're watching cinema. This is So, these are two completely
different things. So, OCD um is an umbrella, all right? And This
is a little bit better. This is a little bit better. This is
just two is an anxiety disorder. So, we're going to call this
anks, okay? So um this is an um- Why not? Anxiety doesn't come
under OCD. umbrella thing where it can have many kinds of different
manifestations. So, one of these manifestations can be POCD,
okay? And I drew this before. So um this can be POCD. And what
is POCD? It is specifically the anxiety of um anxiety of oh oh
my god, I'm so afraid that I am or I'm I'm afraid I'm [__]
it's already gone crazy. He's tied so good with the two sections.
We're already just drawing lines
It's um act, but you are not actually a That does not necessitate
that you are a Does that make sense? So, far do you follow? Yep.
Okay. So um since you are that way, so now let's bring in another
part of the equation, lolly con. I mean Wait wait wait wait wait
wait.
No way. Wait.
Why did Dev just say I knew a person who
Wait, what?
What if exposure therapy is to make you not overly anxious around
children, not children? Yes.
And Dev says I knew a person who
Does he mean from like lolly con to Or wait, what is he Okay,
no I I don't even want to I don't even want to get into that.
Now, let's just say that um
you are so so This is pure right? Well, yes and yes. So, yes
as in it's definitely
Yes as in it's definitely cope. Why are you drawing something
that doesn't need to be drawn? You could just explain this. You
don't need to draw this.
These These aren't even like things that are Like literally,
all she had to do is
I have PCOD POCD.
Consuming doesn't make me a and then explain why.
Anks, OCD, anxiety, POCD.
Anxious about being a
Like none of this is The chart is not helping right now. It's
not helping communicate any concept. So, let's just put the easy
part of the equation out of the way, okay? So, if you are and
you consume Okay? It's pretty obvious why might consume right?
It's because is um you know, a childlike, right? So, since it's
Interesting choice of words. Don't draw on CP childlike. >> childlike.
Um that's why will consume Does this make sense so far? Yeah,
it would be someone who is attracted to the aspect that they
are a child with
features. Okay. Okay, I'm I'm going to make a prediction here.
All this diagram is going to say is it's going
She's Okay, hold on. I'm going to make a prediction about Queenmu
is going to make a prediction about. This diagram's just going
to like basically lay out the fact that she is being called a
or that uh she has POCD. It's going to say this is it's okay
for POCD
people with POCD to consume lolly because they don't have the
primary attraction. There will be no reckoning with like any
of the points or anybody's like questions. It'll just say, "No,
POCD means not
POCD means not I've give I've given myself POCD. That means not
going to be her saying No, I could be a after all, but actually
I've it's just cuz I've got POCD. That That's all she's going
to say with this diagram. That's what I'm That's That's my bet
right now. Now here Now here is a trick question. Ready? Here's
a trick question. Now here is a normal person.
Here's a normal person who does not have OCD, does not have Why
might they consume it? If they're seeking it out specifically,
it would be one of a number of of things that would It would
be they don't have pedophilia defined in the DSM, but they still
have a attraction to children in some capacity, right? It could
either be um as you mentioned, the power dynamic between the
adult and the child, that extreme power dynamic, or it could
also be the more um the more childlike behavior, which can also
be sought out in adult-related like Uh infantilization Yeah,
infantilization. infantilization. And uh and then it could also
Okay, guys, I've got a message from Smith, the Five Nights at
Freddy's enthusiast who was on earlier. "Will you make me famous
with your stream? Just know I'm a pedo. In a fantasy, I would
be with Toy Chica, but in reality, I wouldn't because it would
be weird." It is It's just It's just like that. Be like That's
a good point. Yeah, you also mentioned that you might like stuff
stuff stuff. Oh, I got like oh, I got caught. Um I got caught,
you know, with my promotion stuff. My boss my boss, you know,
employee promotion stuff, right? Like a lot like getting hot
porn is very popular. Also because of guilt. Um yeah, it is very
very popular, right? So So again, this is an- an- another reason
why a normal person might be into lolly. Now, because uh because
a normal person into lolly, this could be a reason why somebody
with OCD might also be into lolly, right? Because So, she's saying
one reason she could be a normal person could be into lolly is
because it is like a guilty thing. They could feel guilt What?
Hot porn is very popular. Also because of guilt. Um yeah, it
is very very popular, right? So So again, this is Is this true?
I don't even know I don't even know if the things she's saying
here are true. I'm already I've already got questions. an- an-
another reason why a normal person might be into lolly. Now,
because uh because
What is caught
Is that like when somebody's stealing something, you catch them,
you like blackmail? Is that what she's talking
Then that's an attraction to like an abusive power. That's like
a very different thing. a normal person into lolly, this could
be a reason why some Like I assume most people who watch blackmail
stuff like that, if she if that's what she's talking about, I
I assume most people who watch that are watching it from the
point of view that they're the blackmailer.
I don't think that mostly just cuz it's like men catching women,
and most men men are the people who consume consume somebody
with OCD might also be into lolly, right? This diagram cleared
up for you guys. Does this clear to you guys? What?
These same reasons. Yeah, it could be a parallel thing as opposed
to being >> Exactly. So, if somebody with POCD could also
be into lolly for the same reasons. Yeah, I I I recognize that.
Here's my question. So, you said that Okay, guys.
Now is a great time to remind you so many of you here, please
like. They're still like considering the Um so so I can explain.
So, for me, what I'm into is that I'm into petite. So I'm into
petite women, all right?
Specifically, I am into like the um Hold on. I just need to go
away. >> Listen, she she's like circumscribing
everything around being a like perfectly while claiming she's
not a She's supposed POCD. No, she will not stop off to all of
the things that are adjacent to being a She will not stop but
she's just not a Okay, the only thing missing here in all the
things that stack up and point in a direction is
directly, okay? She just likes all of the things about kids.
She's all the things about kids except
kids. Except the actual children. Guys, obvi- This is This makes
so much sense to me. Oh my >> All right, what somebody
posted like a lolly in spicy chat and said, "Laugh as I in fire.
Thank you." Uh like I would say probably like B-sized or like
around there, basically B-sized women, right? Um now how that
translates onto chart, it can be anywhere from
to um to to like like like um up to like early 20s. Does that
make sense? So basically, um that is how it looks. However, I
know that whenever I browse and start to dig into it, um whenever
I see there, I feel like my POCD gets triggered. So, when I feel
like my POCD gets triggered, when I actually see the there, I'm
like I'm like, "Dude, SFO is screaming at me to stop, okay? SFO,
I'm sorry. I'm already in
middle, okay? The point is >> I I warned her SFO. I told
her about the We had a long talk about this, so I'm in the middle,
okay? >> Go ahead. I'm literally in the middle. Oh my god.
Jesus Christ. Okay. I tried, Okay. The point is, okay? Yes, I
know Zonia's evil, okay? The point is is that Don't say that.
Listen, no no, I know I know Zonia's going to is going to literally
is I know Zonia's working for spicy chat, okay? Yes, I know,
okay? The point is is um Uh yes yes, okay. All right, fine. Zonia
will be the last one, okay? All right. Zonia, this is why it's
very important for you to be will not be the last combo. This
will not be the >> very good behavior, okay?
This was not the last combo. In fact, Queenmu somehow got six
more videos out of this.
Somehow, in some way, he managed to get six more videos out of
this. After, okay? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 Actually, I can't count. Seven
more streams
out of this.
Amazing. The point here is that Yeah yeah yeah. So, the point
here is that Man, I mi- I miss the old Queenmu when he'd find
some like crazy 20 view lolcow that he could just milk forever.
Now he just does British politics. What is that about? Now it's
just British politics. Who gives a [__] dude? Go
find a the farm. What the My POCD gets triggered, okay? When
I go up searching for Okay? Because I am specifically into petite
whatever. I'm just I'm like I'm just getting. I actually
I I'm I'm mostly kidding, okay? Okay? However, so therefore in
order for me to so in the middle of me searching up for I need
to go seek out exposure therapy on purpose.
Um when I am searching up. So therefore I need to go seek out
on purpose. You get Wait, hold on. I missed I missed that last
part. I was honestly not paying attention. Hold on. Give me a
second. However, so therefore in order for me to so in the middle
of me searching up for I need to go seek out exposure therapy
on purpose. Um when I am searching up. So therefore I need to
Why? Like why? This is This is just totally wrong, right?
Like any therapist will tell you that connecting like you can
connect concepts in your brain by continuously reinforcing, right?
Why would you say, "Okay, I have this like attraction to kids.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to cement the attraction to
kids that scares me with Wouldn't you want to cement that kids
are not to be Why would you try to cement that kids are to be
if you're concerned about being a That doesn't make any sense
whatsoever.
There's no part of that that makes any sense. to go seek out
lolly on purpose. Did you get it now? I Guys, I tried to get
rid of my fear of being a serial killer by playing Grand Theft
Auto and cutting down as many people as I can.
I I play like Oblivion Elder Scrolls Oblivion and I try to kill
as many people as I can in the Assassin's Guild. That's how I
get rid of my fear of being a killer.
I act out Wait, what?
Now, did you get it now?
Did you get it now? Does that make
It's so much more clearer. We've got
For some reason we have POCD under
covertly making it seem as though you can have POCD and be a
Very interesting.
Okay. So >> Everything makes sense, see? No, it it's complicated.
It's hard for me to wrap my brain around. Right, right. I mean
this is why this is why this is why it's mental health is So
you shouldn't have She's saying now you just shut up for a second
and let me think through this cuz now if we if we dropped to
China capitalize on Zoey's moment of confusion here, just start
talking and signing her off. complicated And when I try to explain
to Twitch poll, everyone's going to go like, "Oh my god, you're
a Right? This is This is why This is why it's like Yeah, this
is why it's just it's it's just like nobody will take it the
right way. Hey, listen.
Kleiman thinks you're I think you're Bug thinks you're Kenny
thinks you're He also likes So it's a little weird with Kenny.
But there's one person who can save you, Food Shops. We need
Destiny to go meticulously over this playlist on his stream and
exonerate you, okay? We need the ultimate 30-hour review, except
it's pedable review, okay? Destiny can save you by reviewing
all of this content, all of your past statements on stream, and
helping everybody to understand that you're not really a You
just have to look and have a lot of thoughts about kids to the
point that you are scared to be around kids. You don't trust
yourself around kids, right? But you're not a
Only Destiny can save you. Let's see if Destiny will be willing
to do it. You spent a ton of time on your stream defending him.
Surely
he'll do the same for you. Surely he will do the same for you.
He will he will save you from the allegations, right?
Almost certainly that will happen. I believe it. I believe it.
Don't you guys believe it?
We're We're on a Naruto arc, okay? Believe it. I've never watched
the English dub of Naruto. I can't imagine anything more disgusting,
but I've been told he says this, okay? 1 second. Do we have other
stuff? I We do have other stuff. We have this whole manifesto,
but I also wanted to watch another video. Oh, I'm looking for
another video. Hold on. The I've got a hair in my mouth.
Okay, I'm looking for another video. Oh, I want the one where
she talks about the power fantasies.
That would also be a good one. And then there's one other one
about where she's
streaming. She like posted a video about quitting streaming.
Who sent me this one?
Was it Moral?
It was Moral.
Um
Hello. Uh Food Shops here. Uh hi. If you're watching this video
um and you don't know what's going on
you know, don't worry about it, okay? So
I knew Erudite didn't get that look from from anyone in her personal
life. I knew she stole that from somebody on the internet. God
damn. Now we see Now we get it. Oh, makes sense. >> started
um
content creation uh April
20th. Well, not April 20th. It's a beginning of May.
And uh
uh oh guys
If you're watching this
it means that um I'm no longer on this channel, okay? Because
uh I have quit content creation. Now, why is it that you wonder
why like I quit content creation? Well, you see
I've been See, I mean lots of people assume, you know, um that
there are
There's, you know, like I went through I went through too many,
you know, um stress and hardships and etc., right?
Uh however, it's not it's not really the entire truth, okay?
It's not really the entire truth. So here I I just want to give,
you know, the full context of um why I quit con why I We'll see.
We'll see what happens after she is done hustling with Dan, okay?
We'll see what happens. You know what? I'm sure I I I'm guessing
that Here's Here's the play, guys, okay? This is what Food Shops
needs to do. She needs to show Dan this stream and then she needs
to make Dan understand that she is the only shield that exists
that protects the realms of DGG from me, the big bad anti-fan,
so-called, okay? And that Dan
is actually harming Destiny and Dan needs to protect her as well,
okay? Show Dan this video. Come out clean Come clean to Dan.
Show Dan what's been going on, okay?
surely he will understand that he has to protect you. Surely
Dan will protect you, right? Dan will protect the Absolutely.
Dan will be like, "Oh, you know what? If I if this falls, it
will be like a domino and all of the
or consuming people in my life will fall as a result." I'm sure
he will be convinced, okay? He will be convinced to protect the
Absolutely.
I am quit content creation, okay?
number one, all right?
I have a
So just want to show you guys real
So there's this um
There's this YouTuber named um
uh Kleiman. This is back in the day, okay? This is back in the
day. This is 2 years ago. This is what? This is a year and a
half ago, okay? It's a year and a half ago.
Dude, this was This is when
I don't think I was I don't think I knew Kleiman at all yet at
this point. Like I knew of him. I think we'd had a couple conversations
with Spicy.
But like this is I think This looks like
No, I would have been streaming at this point. I don't think
I would have been streaming with Kleiman yet, but I would have
been streaming at this point.
A very interesting >> This is very interesting how this
goes. Oh, also, you know what I didn't
I didn't understand that if you actually go to Food Shops' channel,
she used to get really mad about my fights with Dan, how I was
like totally backstabbing Dan. I had reasons to be mad at Dan.
Dan was totally making things up about me. You are an actual
getting mad at him, okay? I had actual reasons to be mad at Dan.
And she was like she painted me as like some kind of backstabber.
And now she's like transparently backstabbed Dan. It's very funny.
It's very ironic.
Um yeah, this guy uh
This guy does videos. Now, you know, back in November when the
drama was still going on, I was like um you know, to some degree
semi-beefing with Kleiman or full beefing, whatever,
Yeah, it was uh
You know, I I I thought you know, I was kind of projecting on
the Kleiman, you know, um
Yeah, well I I was
Yeah, this is this is kind of hard to say, but I thought Kleiman
had um a crush on me. Like I thought I thought he had feelings
for me.
What? Wait, what?
She put this ON TAPE?
WHAT? OH, I actually Kleiman and I were friends at this point.
Kleiman and I were definitely friends at this point cuz I remember
he used to raid me and then he used to do his cat face cuz him
and Food Shops were a
I remember now.
Oh, I remember now. Uh-oh. Oh boy. Kleiman Kleiman and Dev? Kleiman
and Dev not so different maybe after all?
They Listen, maybe kindred spirits of a sort. Um
Now I see why Now I see why Kleiman has it so out for Dev, okay?
Now I'll We're putting it together. We're putting it to We're
putting it together. Oh boy. However
uh turns out that I was actually
I'm going to be honest, I think I don't know why or how it happened
or over time but I
I actually have feelings for Kleiman.
for for Quicky, you know, I think maybe Oh, brother. Oh, brother.
OH, BOY.
OH, BOY. >> IT'S because
Maybe it's because he looks like a child. I don't know. That's
my first thought. I'm just spitballing here. Could it be the
fact that Queen Man looks like a child? Is that why she had >> um
you know little wiggler at the bottom a bit too much or something,
but
you know because it's so cute um you know I
I just instantly start thinking of like you know how cute it
would be for me to be with him.
uh but the problem is obviously it's kind of like a you know
forbidden romance kind of scenario. I'm just Dude, what? Dude,
what?
Oh my god.
Oh
boy, this is also a subplot of the Tom x Mantis stuff cuz Tom
was intentionally with Mantis to make her think this was true.
Well, sorry. You're responding to somebody else. You're >> Because you
know like even if I wanted to hit on Queen Man um it would be
risking it because um you know in the uh when I have um DM'd
Queen Man only once uh regarding you know some panel stuff um
I Are you going to to me?
I have a
I can expect it to be leaked, you know.
But now you know like it it it kind of acts as a
you know and like a a free shots repellent because now I'm afraid
that if I confess to Queen Man my true feelings
yeah like he would like it as well, but if I um like for example
if I were to
I wondered why Okay, I didn't follow this that closely. I thought
it was like memes or jokes. I wondered why she hated me so much.
It's because I was hanging out with
I had the one thing she wanted in the whole world.
That's crazy. That's That's crazy, chat. >> Go to our Social
Blade and this is part of the reason why you know I was so into
him.
But Dude. For example, um see I'm here.
Queen Man versus Chuds.
Yeah, let's uh let's compare. Let's compare. Let's compare. So
here this is uh this is Queen Man and this is me. Um you know
I've always had eyes on our Social Blade for quite some time.
Um you know because I I feel as though because we you know we
we we kind of you know started lifting off together, you know
um it was it felt like a sign, right? Now we hit around 1,000
subs I think around the same time. You can see that here our
intersection um I hit 1,000 subs first and then Queen Man hit
it afterwards, but then Queen Man
um and then it just kind of took off from there, you know. And
um I feel as though that when Queen Man uh skyrockets around
here like he's kind of you know it's masculine to take dominance
over you know
Dude, what the [__] is this video?
Dude, quit. This is
Somehow she is just describing a one-sided romance and this is
like an actual hit piece on Queen Man. This is like actually
the worst video I've ever seen. uh a YouTube channel who you
you know kind of This is like somehow this person's totally like
parasocial relationship with Queen Man is a an aura debuff. Jesus
Christ. >> A-locking or something, you know. Um so the
moment that it hit around you know 2K I started to have even
stronger feelings um you know just mainly because
it kind of it kind of it kinds of gives off some degree of numerical
uh masculinity, okay? A numerical masculinity um it's spelled
like that. And yeah like it it it you know if you kind of look
at it kind of looks like a DNA shape, you know. Dude. I Oh boy,
I dude it's disgusting. Why What is
Um I don't >> part of why you know I thought it was fate,
right? Now I I mean I think at this point I kind of accept that
you know Queen Man and I will never be together.
But You don't say. >> something about you know there's
something about that Jewish kid. No no no no no. No no no no
no no no no. You can't give up that easily.
You can't You cannot give up that easily. Come on, man.
But yeah I know there's something about you know there's something
about that Jewish kid. You know that still speaks >> There's just
something about that young lad. There's just something about
him. I don't know why I still have the Connor approved message
up, but let's leave it up there, okay? Let's leave it up there.
Jesus Christ, man. to me to this day, you know. Yeah.
And finally another reason why you know I'm quitting content
creation is because uh because um this person named Map Hit,
all right? From Now Recording. I can find it. So here you can
see Andrew Wilson say something on the lines of um then by that
argument blah blah blah, right? And then it doesn't really matter.
Last day he says do you deem every disabled man less than and
Map Hit from Now Recording commentary community. Okay, so I'm
less than less than a leg. Okay, and then um I say Map Hit laugh
will not fool you. Um and then Map Hit says free shots at 7,000
euro dragons will not fool you either. And I say 7,000 euro dragons
can't consent. Laugh cannot. Um you know um I didn't think of
it much at the time of this little exchange, right? But
He's calling you a obviously. Like bees everybody knows you're
a That is a joke calling you a Are you confused?
Is she confused that she's being called a right now? I realize
now that um
that when I'm looking looking back on it it just kind of you
know like this just kind of hits really hard, you know, like
I feel like I feel like my feelings have been really hurt by
this one and
It's just I can't This seems like a joke, but I can't tell. >> fact
that somebody on Now Recording could
When I saw this reply I was like, man what am I doing with my
life, you know? What like on internet beefing with these complete
randos I'll never meet in person, right? Yeah, and you know this
really this really hurt my feelings. This really hurt my feelings.
And worst of all Map Hit actually goes out of his way to you
know tweet this and you know I just thought you know you know
that that that really hurts, you know? Like kind of putting me
on display you can see it has 58 likes. Um you know like just
just knowing out there that this many people dislike me. I thought
that Map Hit owned me just kind of hurt, you know? Like it it
just straight up hurt. It is what it is, right? And um This still
seems like a meme.
Yeah, it's just
Yeah, it's not cool. It's just not cool. Yeah. Yeah. Also you
know another another thing is um
I was thinking back to a call in that I had um regarding quitting
content creation. You can see um Wait, hold on. Hold on. So so
at that point he says he just tells me to quit content creation.
Um
Uh you don't you don't need to know the full context, but
you know but but you know now looking back now looking back there's
another time in which uh you know I I have um you know talked
about you know quitting content creation. So
So I just want to go here. There's just There's one person who
called in. There's what I want to talk about, you know. God,
why is it why is it so hard to find? Jesus. Okay, here. Is that
um you know Um that at some point you know it seems like it was
2 months ago you know the caller came in the caller came in and
you know told me to quit content Um
But uh you can see that um I originally basically uh all you
need to know really is that you know this guy just told me to
quit content creation because I was getting you know I wasn't
really getting anywhere, you know. And you know I I I began to
think back to this moment ago, you know what? You know what?
I think I'm I think I'm going to heed your advice, you know I
think. I think I'm going to go out there and get a real job because
uh you know it's just it's just not my cup of tea, you know?
You a little a little too I don't know if I can handle this speech,
you Like when when people when people you know kind of bully
me and you know talk talk [__] about me like with
all the Map Hit stuff. Like it seems as though like I'm getting
all the things I don't want, right? Like people you know kind
of going after me, but also I can't get the things I actually
want like you know Queen Man's attention and love, right? So
really you know I'm like what what's the point? What's the point,
right?
This is like I think it's a bit I seems like it's a bit now,
okay? Um So listen. Um Queen Man if you're listening to this
But then she did quit shortly after this, didn't she? For like
quite a long period of time. I thought she quit for quite a while
after this. >> I just want to be with you. All right. Come
over and we can make some things make some things happen. I got
you. I don't know I know this is really dating.
I love you. I love you, Queen Man. Let's actually make free shots
happen. Let's actually This is the most disgusting form of like
psychotic psychological attack. Jesus Christ. >> hours
on free shots. This is kind of my last attempt to have you know
I guess going about this
all of this is just a little it was just a little it's just all
a little too
>> too much. >> Okay. You know Bro, what is this?
And for the rest of the people in my crowd Jidion is ultra cooked
on Destiny drama.
Thank you. >> What is this? Thank you for being there.
What is this even? What could I be ultra cooked on? Bro, I do
I even comment on What was I commenting on that she was >> is
Tactical Templar. To be frank, I don't really give a about this
far right wing person, but I just if that makes sense. What was
I commenting He um the reason why uh he has helped Kiwi Farms
find Rose um and the way he enticed Kiwi Farms into finding Rose
is because Oh, hold on. Let's see. Let's Wait wait wait. Should
we Should we comment on some of this stuff? We comment on What
Destiny has C Sam, so after all this case he'll be Dude, oh my
god. Actual like the the the most individuals straight up becomes
an extremely successful content creator, okay? I'm sorry. Jidion
is just a completely lost cause, okay? Like Jidion doesn't have
talent. He doesn't He He doesn't have the skill to practice being
a good commentator either. The current narrative is that Destiny
has C Sam, so
Okay, I I feel like if you have some good criticisms for my commentary,
maybe >> this case he'll be arrested. Let's see. Let's
see. Oh my god. Actual
To be honest, I just can't actually take her opinion seriously.
So Oh like the the the most individuals straight up Yeah, I don't
know. Also now now that I'm floating around the possibility that
Jidion is like botting. Like I'm just I'm just looking at his
viewer count. It's always it's always around this like like above
300. It's always above 300. He could be covering the most boring
ever and it's still at least 300. And remember people on Kick
and Twitch have no incentive to like not use bots, right? Because
it doesn't [__] them in the algorithm. We should
all wonder a little bit.
I get curious about this too, but my chatters have been consistent
the whole
The chatters are consistent with the view numbers. Listen, I
I Sometimes I'm like, wait, why why are the numbers high right
now?
Doesn't matter to me. >> Why why Why does she have DG merch
on if she's like totally trafficked or whatever? If she had no
idea, I'm curious about that. Oh hold on. I want to hear about
the the commentary on my commentary, okay? If she was trafficked,
why does she have DG merch on? Okay? The question the operative
reason the way we we ask this, okay? The question is
either she was sent this by somebody who could get the picture
for her or she's aware of Destiny she knows Destiny specifically.
Right? One of the two. Well, you mean you mean someone who's
a victim who is possibly coerced into into wearing that for authenticity
for Oh, so she if she was coerced into wearing it. Oh,
she was coerced into wearing it. So then this was shipped to
the trafficker.
Right? It was shipped to her or it was shipped to the trafficker.
So why was it so difficult to find her or the trafficker?
That's the question. >> Chicken Destiny? Yeah. I mean she
wonders if there's a really good story here. Maybe.
But this this picture was posted by Destiny he went like Aquafarms
you're too incompetent to find this person. And then when they
did dox her based on this picture that Destiny posted he went
why do you guys think I helped them find That was his proof that
he Because at the time he didn't think of her as a victim. Right?
If if that makes sense. What did he think of her as? Is this
person out of their Well, at the time he just thought she was
a totally disconnected young woman that he should get doxxed.
Well, at the time he was like yeah, we should dox this person.
Uh what? I think uh basically the whole time he thought it was
the boyfriend who leaked this stuff. So there would still be
the victim of revenge porn. No?
Or not even revenge porn. Sorry, not revenge porn but just having
their privacy violated. They would still be a victim here in
some way.
At the time um the reason why uh I I guess uh you I mean it clearly
it led to her identity being found. So like sorry um the leaks
from from Solo led to her like online being found. I don't know
how you classify that the actual C-SAM posted it. How many subs
for two more hours of Food Shops content? Oh, we're just doing
this for a while. We'll see. >> Rose um and the why he
enticed Kiwi Farms into finding Rose.
let's listen. >> Right? If that makes sense. At the time
um the reason why uh he has helped Kiwi Farms find Rose.
Okay, so she accepts that he did help Kiwi Farms find Rose. Now
why you would help a group of people who are known for harassing
others
find this person who had their pictures posted online who we'd
already sorry, who we already assumed or suspected was a minor
we've been told she was a minor. Why would you help them dox
her? This person who was a child when this stuff was posted?
Or when this when this picture was sent?
Right? That's still that's not a good reason. Oh, well, I thought
she wasn't being trafficked. That's a reason to dox somebody?
To help Kiwi Farms dox somebody so they could be harassed? This
is all you know, this all being brought up again because at this
point Destiny was like oh harassing this person.
Right? It's like dude, what are you talking about? You're the
one who
posted the information critical in doxing her. >> Um and
the why he enticed Kiwi Farms into finding Rose is because at
the time Steven thought that she was um an adult who should be
around 20 or 21 now and was colluding with Solo in order to go
after him or some When had he ever thought that Rose was colluding
with Solo to go after him? I don't believe that was his thought.
He didn't say it was his thought. And why would he dox her instead
of just going to the cops? Okay? The reason we ask why was the
shirt posted or what how did she get the shirt is because the
shirt through the merch through the whoever registered the merch
around where her college is, right? Whoever registered sorry
on the site to buy the merch. That person is obviously
going to be related to the case.
Shouldn't it be really easy to find this person and sue them?
If it's if it's her if it's Solo
either one of them.
Why would this information have to go to Kiwi Farms? Why was
Kiwi Farms critical to include here? The site that apparently
is harassing people and ruining Destiny's life.
Why was that like a critical element to include here? Right?
Like there's like plausible reasoning to do something like that.
Obviously in retro
What is the plausible reasoning to do that? If if she is not
the trafficking victim what is the plausible reason to try to
get Kiwi Farms to dox her?
When she's supposed to have been a minor back here. The answer
is Destiny doesn't care about other people and he wanted her
doxxed so that they could find out she was 18 and then he could
go look she's 18 I'm not a I'm not a I don't have
Womp womp.
Okay, womp womp. Turns out she was actually a minor at the time.
Apparently now she was trafficked. Okay, so you gave all this
information to the cops, right? No? Respect. It is kind of sucky
and it is unfortunate that in order to vindicate Steven such
attention has to be brought to her life, right? >> Didn't
think she was 17. Was he like why do you think I helped Kiwi
Farms dox her? And somehow GGers go to my comments pointing this
out and go well, you doxxed her though. What? So remember when
when LEB said Destiny should go to the police he responded I
have nothing to give them. Remember the only reason >> Well,
now they hide her face. Yeah. I mean however I don't think Steven
wanting Kiwi Farms
I didn't show I didn't show anything but the Willie video in
the same way everybody else did.
Sorry, I I If you defended Willie at all in his whole doxing
thing, okay? I did zero a zero percent of the damage there.
>> should remove you from um the possibility of like uh
sorry from from the fact that it is still the anti-fans that
went after her. They made the choice themselves to go after her,
right? Like sure you can criticize
You say the anti-fans. Who does that mean? She just does his
webbing thing. I'm saying I had nothing to do with this. You
cannot blame me for this. That is my criticism that is my point.
She's not listening, right? I had nothing to do with this and
she goes well, the anti-fans went after her trying to web me
into it because she's too actually understand anything. Besides
Steven. >> Or make her own point or argue that I did it
myself, right? She can't do that. So she just does the anti-fans.
She uses the tools Destiny's given her. She's just she's just
a useful idiot for him, >> And you can criticize Steven
for Oh, there's just no nothing going on here. Nothing going
on here. >> I want Kiwi Farms to go find her in the first
place thing, right? But at the same time um after that information
is out um and after like the whole like she may be a minor at
the time was out after all that [__] was out you
have to ask yourself like well, you could be using that information
and trying to bring Solo to justice yourself, right? There
Oh, but did that. I don't know if Destiny did
Did that.
Submitted a Nick Vic complaint, right? Like a national
Oh, it's like a national child protection thing.
He he submitted that under the auspices of protecting Rose. Has
Destiny filed anything to the cops? Has he sent anything to the
cops or any child protection agency with regards to Solo? Has
he taken the information he has put it together and given it
to the cops? I hope so. Cybert did something. That as far as
it didn't mention Destiny in the Rose complaint by the way. >> other
ways for you to get around to um you know, acting accordingly
especially when you know, C is involved. There could have been
other ways to get around to acting accordingly.
Like well, you could be using that information and trying to
bring Solo to justice yourself, right? There could have been
other ways for you to get So Cybert did that. Destiny still said
he was harassing um he was harassing people. He was like disgusting
a a dox or a Kiwi Farmer. None of that as far as I know I'm true
is true. Cybert forms seemingly very parasocial relationships
with people. Probably a little
I don't know like there's maybe a red flag there but as far as
I could tell from the stuff he posted of Rose it just seemed
like he was concerned.
You know, is it appropriate to send messages to people? No, but
did he do anything a private eye wouldn't have done? Like if
they if they let's say Pixie's team couldn't afford a private
investigator. Did Cybert do anything a private investigator wouldn't
have done?
I don't see it but maybe somebody else can point it out to me.
If if that's the case I mean I would consider you know
I would consider judging him for that you know, possibly banning
him from the community or something. If he did something like
totally crazy and out of But realistically I see nothing he did
that's outside of what a private investigator would do. He emailed
some people he said hey, are you aware of these things? Helped
Rose take down some
Get around to um you know, acting accordingly especially when
you know, C is involved. But what did they do
So you could have done some things to act accordingly when C
is involved. So she is now agreeing that Destiny has
and sent to multiple people. He's retained it for a long time
and that he was obviously referring to C in the Willie Mac conversation.
Well, that's nice. Thank you Food Shops. I appreciate that you
can cut through the Destiny was obviously retaining C. He obviously
has. He's lied and said his lawyers told him to do so. They would
never have done that. I'm glad that Food Shops is agreeing with
all of the anti-fan quote unquote talking points. Thank you Food
Shops. >> What did they do instead? They used that information
to harass families to um What what does harassing families here
Was was Cybert told to stop con Hey, please stop contacting me.
Did he not help Rose take some stuff down? I If you could show
me what the harassment is I would love to see the harassment.
I do think it's like weird to get involved personally. That's
my personal opinion. But if I saw him harassing people if I saw
him like going after people unnecessarily I would ban him from
my community. So I none of that personally but maybe they could
show me what was inappropriate.
Beyond just being a red flag.
Um go after people to make everyone's lives harder, right?
Whose life was made harder? Uh By the way, the entire
operating principle here the entire reason she's doing this is
she's saying anyone's life it's just Destiny's life was made
slightly harder. And that is realistically the only thing these
people need to hate you. Have you made Destiny's life slightly
harder? Yes? Okay, we hate you. You should be doxxed. You should
be killed.
>> Wow. Um so so it's not like because because every single
time you confront them on this they keep on saying well, I mean
it it wasn't it wasn't it Steven's fault in the first place for
trying to get Kiwi Farms to dox her? Yes, but you guys did all
the harm. You guys are responsible for the harm.
What harm?
Cybert helped Rose avoid harm. Yeah, Cybert exactly. Cybert helped
Rose avoid harm. He talked to her. He helped her take profiles
down.
And in return for for Cyra helping this
in return what did he get? Destiny doxing him. Are you serious?
It's com- it's complete horse
Oh oh these people don't engage with what I say. Okay, Destiny
doxes the guy who actually helped Rose who actually did something
to go after Solo. What what did Destiny do to go after Solo?
He complained that Pixie was suing him like
canceled his lawsuit that was supposed to be trying to find Solo
like a [__] Destiny is the ass like a [__]
at all times, right? Doxing is one thing because Steven needed
to know who she is in order for like in order for like lawsuit
and you know legal reasons.
So, Destiny doxes her for the lawsuit.
Destiny tried to he posted unique pieces of personal information,
tagged Kiwi Farms, knowing by the way, what is Kiwi Farms known
for? What does Destiny think Kiwi Farms is used for? It's used
to harass people around him. And so he posted pictures of somebody
they were looking for, helping them find her, not caring about
the outcome of her being found. Destiny directly understood that
this doing this would lead to her being harassed. Not by Cyra,
not by anybody in my community, but by Kiwi Farmers, okay? Could
lead to her being harassed. And he did it anyway. Doesn't give
a [__] about her. Wanted her harassed by all for
all intents and purposes. Otherwise, he could have given those
photos and what information he had on the merch sales to a private
investigator to go and look into it.
Would have been really simple.
There is no excuse, there's no possible excuse for using Kiwi
Farms. And Food Chops and anybody else who defends Destiny will
do this kind of uh
trying to convince you otherwise, right? Oh my god, he he had
to retain the What is he supposed to delete stuff? No, you literally
hire a firm to handle it. You Sorry, you
He didn't have to delete his logs. He could have just hired a
firm to go and retain his logs for him that would have created
like an audit record and would have saved all of that stuff as
a third party and he would have had them be able to testify that
everything was maintained with perfect integrity, okay? Sorry,
not the not the But this he had to give it to the cops and then
delete it.
What is he supposed to just delete this? Yes. His lawyers told
him not to. No, they didn't. No, they didn't, okay? They don't
actually address any of the real concerns. They just pretend
to be whenever the actual concerns come up. Um however, you guys
are the ones that actually did the harassing. So, you can't just
say, well, you can't Where? Where? Where is the evidence of harassment?
What is harassment?
can't blame us for harassing her uh because you were the one
that got that to happen for like yeah again it it like it just
I am not associated with Ki- with KF. KF doesn't like me. I don't
care, okay? I don't I don't look at their posts to like get information.
I don't do any of that. But I also
if I were to do that, okay? If I were to go to Kiwi Farms to
get information, there's nothing wrong with consulting Kiwi Farms
for information. All right?
I will never I will never judge somebody who went to a Kiwi Farms
thread to find some piece of information and they they look at
like a tweet or a video clip and they look at it and they just
judge it on its merits, okay? If you want to go there and read
psychological profiles of Destiny and make them up your like
your life and all of your critiques, I think that's probably
not correct. I think there's not there's some bias there. It's
people memeing, it's people being like edgy. Uh yeah, obviously
Destiny himself used KF significantly for the Cathals Manifesto.
Yes, this is true. Right? I've no problem with people using KF
for that stuff. But like I am not associated. I don't dox people.
I don't let doxes in my community. I don't I don't want people
doxed, right?
Certainly not content creators I have a problem with, certainly
not content creators in general. I There have been like one or
two instances of like romantic entanglements where people said
each others names or something and we let them back. But realistically,
no, [__] off.
Destiny's community cannot say the same thing. You openly asked
you openly said you hope that Dan gets doxed and swatted just
today.
Disgusting behavior, man. just found the Rose person. Let's talk
about Kiwi Farms. Was because I posted the pics in chat to bait
them into looking. Seems pretty stupid to do that if I thought
she was 17, huh? Also remember Destiny encouraging anti-fans
to harass her family until she suffered a deposition with Pixie.
Exactly. Remember when that Where's the harassment? Again, can
somebody send me Cyra's harassment?
What I saw was like three emails, four four cold emails to emails
that he didn't know if they had if they were receiving stuff
through. And by the way, if he just passed those on to Pixie,
would it be fine? If he just passed those email addresses on
to Pixie, would that be totally fine? That happened. Actually
it didn't happen. Yeah. So, the
Dude the harassment she just advocated for Dan's wife was harassing
her at her job, okay? The harassment that Cyra did so quote unquote
is cold emails.
A few cold emails. Again, show me any evidence of real harassment
of multiple emails being asked to stop sending multiple emails,
switching emails to keep sending emails, right? Show me that
Don't show me a couple cold emails.
That's [__] insane. The picture that this black cat
person is going off about is the actual doxes that Destiny posted,
the actual like personal like She's she's in chat um pretty often,
I think. information posted with a malicious purpose to have
Kiwi Farms to look for her. terminally online And this person
is virtue signaling about how I don't know WillyMacs the bad
guy? How But But just wait, it gets better because actually that's
not that's not what she maintains. Just give it a second. It
gets worse than that. Okay, it gets worse than that. There's
one more tweet. What is this one? New court filings reveal that
Destiny never even spoke to Rose. It was her ex-boyfriend the
entire time. Good job to deranged anti-fan communities for pushing
this innocent girl to be doxed then blasting her all over the
internet. Again, Dest-
Destiny literally is the one who doxed.
He posted the picture they used to find her, right? So crazy.
Destiny is the person who doxed her. That is doxing. When you
post PII, uniquely No, this
Let me see. Black Cat is too powerful,
Black Cat is way too powerful, dude. Literally no comment on
anything I'm saying, right? She agrees with everything I'm saying.
Just be To be clear, when she doesn't respond to what I'm saying,
it's because she agrees. What the Like I'm pretty sure she only
has like what like less than 1,000 followers or some [__]
like that. Like less than 1,000 followers and like every single
major streamer at some point has had Black Cat on the
on on their screens. It's just it's so crazy. I don't know. identifiable
PII with a malicious intent that is doxing. I have more than
followers than you. of doxing to not post like the full doxes,
but it is doxing. Another completely manufactured drama at the
expense of victims created by by and for creepy stalkers. So,
this is clearly a defense of Destiny even though she doesn't
want to say that, right? Clearly her attempting to defend Destiny.
Very Now, the very interesting thing about this is what she's
saying is this first party testimony From what I know it like
Black Cat doesn't even like Destiny all that much, I think, right?
Like I'm pretty sure they have their own Dude this is like it's
so Trump. Dude everything about Destiny's community is just the
same as like the Trump phenomenon, okay? You remember how people
used to post online they're like, I don't like Trump, but I don't
like Trump, but he kind of has a point here. I don't like Trump
I don't like Destiny, but I don't like Destiny, but disagreements
Come on, dude. Come on, dude. you should tell you like, oh my
god, why would any woman defend Destiny or whatever, right? Well,
I mean because women care about justice and they care about um
how um how other women could discredit like their own you know
stories and [__] like that, right? And people like
Pixie makes all women look bad. So, it's like yeah, of course
like women care about this. Like yeah, I don't know. From
From Rose. Zero engagement with anything I've said. Is being
real Who is Black Cat? Is she a hater? No, she's on our side.
Like she's like our side coded, huh? who who is on our side Totally
and it's funny how much they mold over her. It's just so stupid.
But even if you dis- even if you didn't include that even if
you thought Andrew Butler was a totally reliable, always truthful
actor, this would be first party testimony of her experience
which apparently these years think is respectable and is evidence
now. Thank god because we have hallelujah. Okay, fantastic point
from this guy over on the right here, okay? Fantastic point.
Hey, this is first party testimony from somebody. If that's reliable,
if that's evidence, then can't we just say that Abby's testimony
is credible or reliable? Okay, yeah. Pretty confident that they
don't think it should be dismissed, right? Right? Yes, obviously
it's already a very stupid Yes, your honor the the child porn
receipt was actually sent to me by an a
get Abby keeps dodging [__] All of my haters get
owned. I obtained my child from a creepy trafficker. I Okay,
I All right. Uh How like just by the way, okay?
Surely surely
Abby keeps dodging [__] This is just Destiny lying
they she's never been at least up until the last time I watched
him talk about it the last time I covered it. He had still not
filed a deposition or filed a a subpoena subpoenaed her for a
deposition. He was subpoenaing her for logs. We've gone from
Destiny is for sure a predator to oh maybe he's a predator, but
he'll still get [__] Wait, he's totally a predator.
He ab- absolutely violates tons of women's
Wait, no? No?
I'm talking about oh Destiny's definitely like a has switched
to well, he got his child from a child sex trafficker and not
from the child directly. And he has now argued that this makes
him innocent of all charges.
Which is obviously an insane argument. That is the point. You
are totally changing the point. You're straw manning. This is
the definition of a straw man. So, you totally dodge ignore all
of the arguments that are inconvenient that you can't address
which is most of them. And then this one you just straw man me.
You don't actually address the point. You are completely incapable.
to oh well, I mean I guess he accidentally ended up with that
[__] anyway. So, um I guess uh maybe he'll get uh
like dude No, uh the allegation is that he received child from
somebody who is claiming to be 18 or 19. That in and of itself,
while there were red flags and he's obviously looking to take
to do risky behaviors because he has himself described how you
shouldn't get anywhere close to the line as an online content
creator. You're set for life. Why the [__] would
you [__] with somebody who's young, who's really
young, who might put you in in like territory where you're doing
something illegal? That's insane. That's his prescription, okay?
But, beyond that
he was informed that she was a minor long after receiving the
itself, okay? And instead of deleting instead of deleting the
logs, any images he had, he just ignored the fact that he was
told she was a minor and retained it for a long period of time.
He retained it, sent it to multiple people, okay, looking for
this person, and then he said, "Andrew Breitbart told me I could
retain it." Now, I personally don't believe Andrew Breitbart
would tell a client, "Yes, break the law, retain child
But, that's what Destiny claims and that he will claim on the
internet that he's not lying anymore. Like, he's he's just oh,
I'm telling the truth. No, Andrew Breitbart told me to retain
that child. I have to retain it for my court case. It is not
admissible. Child is not admissible in civil court in the state
of Florida. You cannot possess it. That is not a reason to possess
it. He was never told that and he has absolutely admitted to
retaining it. Okay? That's the allegation.
He was told it was child. He went, "Nah, I don't believe you."
and kept it.
So, the child trafficker told him it was child. Yeah, I've revealed
to Destiny it was actually child the whole time.
And Destiny goes, "Nah, I don't believe you. I'm going to keep
it. My lawyer said I could." Okay, just to make it clear what
the allegation is. The allegation isn't hasn't changed. That's
just a new allegation that came about by Destiny doxxing this
woman and proving that she was a minor when they sent it.
how do you live with yourself with how like stupid you sound?
Oh my god, like you're just
That's really ironic that you asked that. I can sit here, I can
have this discussion, I can have this discussion in real time.
I don't prep any of this. This is super easy for me to do on
the >> So stupid. I don't I don't
You move you you keep on moving back the goal posts like constantly
because you know that you can't maintain that ground for long,
right? Uh Destiny has recorded videos consensually with multiple
people and sent those videos not consensually, without their
be them being aware the same day or within a day or two of recording
the video. So, he he talks to somebody, he has this relationship
with them, he records videos with them. They're of the understanding
that those videos will remain private. Those videos are sent
to other women, sometimes before they've even left his apartment.
Okay? There are multiple instances of this. That is an allegation.
I And by the way, if I'm lying, Destiny, sue me for defamation,
you disgusting
Okay? Sue me for defamation if I'm lying. You know it's true.
You know that some of these people still haven't come
And you're just hoping that your harassment campaign has the
nice added effect of keeping them all silent on the
Or you could Hey, you said you've doxxed me. Sue me for defamation.
Make my year, dog. Sue me for defamation.
Go off, king. Go off, king.
Like So, yeah, it's all this is insane. Good memes. Yeah, so
this is Destiny actually gets it correct here. It's just a claim.
It's literally not even it's we don't even know if it's true.
But, we do agree that For me, for me, okay? For me,
I know about these women, I know about these other allegations
that are out I don't reveal it.
I think that's their responsibility, okay? They have they have
all the information they need to to sue this guy if they want
to, to publicize it if they want to, but that's up to them, okay?
I, unlike Destiny, wouldn't want somebody doxxed or harassed
just for my own personal benefit.
Okay? I, unlike Destiny, will just say that's their information,
those are allegations to make. All right?
And that's that's the way we handle that. Here's the evidence.
Both Queenman and I would agree that this is evidence. It should
be considered. It should be you know, examined at trial. Where's
the Willy tweet on this though?
Yeah, it also it's okay, if this is true, it's kind of funny
to me that Queenman is trying to avoid Destiny as much as possible
on his stream, but then it's very clear to me. It's very clear
to me that Queenman is still unhinged about this, right? Because
Queenman still talks about this recently on his Twitter. Like,
he still is coping and investing himself. He's just not talking
about it on
Uh no, the the thing is is there's just no upside to talking
about it.
Like, the cabal of DGGers, the awaiting the rapists awaiting,
the DGG community, these people will harass us until the end
of our days if we actually engage this way, right? I've just
stopped caring at this point.
Queenman does care. Queenman's got YouTube. He doesn't want to
get his like He He just wants to run his own career. He can run
it with off of different content, okay?
I don't care anymore. I'm at the point I'm past caring now. That
Unfortunately, Destiny has made this like a like a sink or swim
situation for me. He's going to continue to pressure my community
to dox people in my community with no actual reason to do so,
right? Just out of pure spite. He does not have an actual reason.
He will threaten to dox people in my community. He's turned it
into a sink or swim situation. I have to actually go and lay
these things out and continue to fight this battle. I don't want
to. I'd love to move on to other content, but he is not going
to let it go. So, I have to continue.
Unfortunate, okay? Queenman, lucky for him, he doesn't get the
same [__] going on his stream because it looks bad.
Um but like just it's so stupid. Like, this [__]
is just so ridiculous.
Absolutely zero engagement with anything I said. She She just
lets it play, plays her video game, goes, "Huh, that's dumb.
Huh, these guys are really dumb." and then moves on. What kind
of disgusting
loser consumes this You just want to watch a play coded games
while listening to my voice and then they go, "Actually, this
guy was dumb. Actually, this guy was dumb. I didn't listen, but
this guy was
That's what we're watching. That's what this is. Let's Let's
keep Let's keep listening or Let's keep reading here. Listening,
Jesus. Just for future reference, Rose should have refused to
answer a question under the grounds of self-incrimination, not
lying to the judge. These people have no idea how the legal system
works.
Uh she could have said fifth amendment,
She could have said fifth amendment. Is it a deposition though?
I don't know I don't know if she had a lawyer there or not. I
have no idea how that deposition went. She might have just been
there by her herself and and lied instead. She could have absolutely,
if she had legal counsel, taken the fifth, pled the
But then, why didn't ABMC show up to court? If she had Wait,
although if she plays the fifth, doesn't that just signal to
other like law enforcement they need to look into this? Oh, I'm
not going to answer because of self-incrimination.
Wouldn't that be really bad? I feel like that would be really
bad. You're talking about the make a tour following Destiny college
tour call unpedal America. Nah, I'm I'm not doing that.
Um let's see. Then why didn't ABMC show up at court? She was
not subpoenaed. She was not actually asked by either party to
show up in court.
How are these people so stupid? She wasn't asked to show up in
court by
Why would she have to?
It's a It's a sub like it's a uh what do you call it? Like a
lower court hearing. It's a magistrate court hearing on based
on a motion.
The motion got the denied, but they just they just amended the
complaint and added the ABMC stuff into the complaint. It doesn't
have to be a part of that trial. That that that hearing. There
was no reason. It means nothing that it wasn't a part of that
hearing. That's just you repeating what Destiny has told you.
You're a pathetic loser. You bears ABMC to Rose, but bro, ABMC
won't even respond to subpoena, let alone give a deposition.
She's not been asked She was not asked to be deposed. She wasn't
asked for any of that. She wasn't asked to be at the hearing.
Those are just things Destiny makes up to pretend that they're
important.
And by the way, I actually don't even think Pixie will win this
case. I've seen no evidence that leads me to believe Pixie will
win this case. Currently, as the evidence stands, and this has
been the case since I don't know, like 3 weeks, 4 weeks after
it was
I don't see evidence that makes me believe she'll win the case.
Holy cow, Jstark is so aggressive. Yeah, why would anyone ever
want to come on his show if he's just going to insult you if
you disagree? Say what you will about Steven. Wait, what? Oh
yeah, you're right. No, you're No, what? Destiny never ever ever
insults people. Dude, is this serious?
This has to be a joke, right?
There's no way. There's just absolutely
way that somebody just said this. For real? Jstark trying to
say we should wear weigh a declaration by Andrew Breitbart and
ABMC evenly. Um yeah, their testimony? It's just testimony. Yes.
Uh actually, it's I believe it's third-party testimony. Technically,
you should weigh ABMC's testimony more heavily. Right? Andrew
Breitbart is just doing hearsay. He is He is testifying in in
a what what do you call it? A motion about what he he says Abby
said or Rose said.
Jstark's straw man voice makes me laugh every time. Based. Love
this guy.
Huh, actually huh huh huh huh huh. His argument is dumb because
if they really gave a [__] they would just subpoena
They have subpoenaed Discord, you stupid This is These are the
people we're up against. And the The other thing about Queenman
not covering it, me not covering it for a long time is the fact
that I'm correct means nothing to these people, right? The fact
that I'm correct in what I say means nothing. The fact that Destiny
has changed his story a thousand times, continues to dox people,
threaten to dox people who have done nothing to him except not
like him
Right? That means nothing to them. There's like no hope with
these people. Yeah, I'm lucky. Dude, this is going to be freaking
wild if the investigation discovers that Pixie, Lauren, and Solo
colluded to blackmail Steven for a million-dollar payday.
Oh, is this the same guy who said Wait, what did he say up here?
That Destiny is always really nice to people?
Why would anybody ever come on Jstark's show if Why would they
ever come on his show?
Incredible stuff. Wait, is this the Tysko debate?
Oh, this person is like a J This is the Tysko debate. Tysko got
in this,
I'm not going to watch anymore. I just wanted to watch a little
bit and see if it had changed, see if they actually engaged with
anything. It turns out, again, no, they don't engage at all.
They're just a lazy loser who gets a bunch of views off of my
content
by playing video games and not engaging
Great state of affairs over here on YouTube. Okay. All right.
I think I'm probably not going to go through the manifesto here
tonight. It was a late start to the stream. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on. The content creation quitting thing.
I do think that was just a meme.
what can you do?
Uh unfortunately, I really do think she was in love with Queen
Man. So, unlucky. That one I'm going to always pretend was was
real. The map hit thing was over the top. Oh,
can't April Fools the hair.
Gross. Okay, I think that is it. We're going to probably spend
some more time going over the food shops stuff at some point.
And in the meantime, what else we're going to do? I think I'm
going to go play Civ or something.
I'll be back tomorrow.
God, I I I swear at some point I got to stop playing Civ cuz
I'm like waking up later and later in the day and it's not great,
okay? Oh, [__] I also uninstalled it. I got to install
it again. Okay. All right. I'm going to go play Civ and I'll
talk to you guys tomorrow. Bye. Good night. See you later. Bye-bye.